the biden administration finally admits
we'll be leaving hundreds if not
thousands of americans and green card
holders behind in afghanistan according
to the white house it's time to rely on
the taliban and joe biden can't be
bothered to answer questions about any
of it i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben will get to all the news in just one
moment first here is your reminder your
cell phone bill it is just too high and
there's no reason you should be paying
that amount of money to your cell phone
provider given the fact that you could
be getting the exact same coverage over
at puretalk usa for a fraction of the
price if you're with verizon or att or
t-mobile you're simply paying too much
it's time to switch over to puretalk
puretalk could save your family over 800
a year you got the same great coverage
because pure talk is actually on the
exact same network as one of the big
three but at a fraction of the price and
switching is as easy as switching out
your sim card you can keep your phone
keep your number or get huge discounts
on the latest iphones and androids plus
right now you can get unlimited talk
text in six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you go over on data
they're not going to charge you for it
there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs and why they are the
preferred wireless partner of amac from
your cell phone they'll pound 250 say
ben shapiro save an additional 50 off
your very first month that is pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started again
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro's have an
additional 50 on your first month of
pure talk usa coverage and save hundreds
of bucks down the road with pure talk
usa alrighty so first the updates on
hurricane ida so it has apparently taken
out all power essentially in new orleans
there are 14 lines into new orleans from
the power companies and 13 of them are
apparently down which means that for
some three weeks people are going to be
without air conditioning and without
power unless they have a generator which
is just insane according to the new york
times
in a statement on sunday night entergy a
power company with 2.9 million customers
across the south said that all eight
transmission lines that power the new
orleans area were out of service and
that it was not clear when power might
be restored more than 199 000 customers
in jefferson parish part of the greater
new orleans region were without
electricity according to poweroutage.us
which tracks utility performance across
the country more than 193 000 customers
were without power in orleans county
while about 11 000 were without power in
plaquemines parish south of the city
before the outage new orleans entergy
said that based on historical
restoration times people in the direct
path of the storm could be without power
for as long as three weeks which is a
humanitarian disaster in its own right
the the generators are not going to be
sufficient obviously for that amount of
power
the the hurricane has at this point
slowed in speed both in terms of the
wind speed as well as the the pace of
movement over land it's now down to
about 60 miles an hour as opposed to 150
when it first hit land so hopefully it
will continue to weaken and um and the
biden administration is saying that they
will be there for whatever support is
necessary here's the president yesterday
we've already pre-positioned resources
that we know are going to be needed
and equipment and response teams in the
region
this includes 2.5 million meals
and 3 million liters of water
we've got generators in place and we're
in close touch with the power providers
to get and restore power as soon as
possible because a lot of it a lot of
it's going to go out
and we should be prepared that it can
take a long time no matter how much
we've pre-positioned which we have
that it's going to take a long time for
a lot of to get back up it could take a
matter of weeks for some places
now the good news is that the levees in
new orleans so far have held apparently
the infrastructure fixes that were done
in the aftermath of katrina have so far
been solid so we'll continue to bring
you the latest on that situation
obviously meanwhile the debacle in
afghanistan is coming to its
semi-terminus tomorrow it is scheduled
to do so when all american troops are
withdrawn from afghanistan leaving
behind hundreds if not thousands of
american citizens and american green
heart green card holders and certainly
tens or hundreds of thousands of people
who worked with the united states
government during the last 20 years joe
biden for his part continues to not
answer questions it's it's an amazing
thing i mean the fact that joe biden
will not answer simple questions about
what's going on in afghanistan where
we're currently going to be leaving
behind again hundreds if not thousands
of american citizens and certainly
thousands of american green card holders
it's pretty astonishing so yesterday
while he was making his announcements
about hurricane ida a reporter asked
about afghanistan and he simply refused
to answer the question and then sort of
turn his back on them
i'm not saying i'm not supposed to take
any questions but go ahead mr president
on afghanistan i'm not gonna answer
again can you see if they're still in it
okay
that's unbelievable i'm sorry that's
unbelievable he's the president of the
united states has no place to go he has
no place to go he simply just turns his
back on the reporter
that's amazing and then he actually is
directed the wrong direction he starts
to walk off in the wrong direction and
then has to walk back in the other
direction this president is not
competent he is not with it he is
certainly not capable of running the
country at this point in time and that
is perfectly obvious and then in a bit
of a debacle yesterday that is being
undercovered by the media because if it
were donald trump you know it would be
you know the the entire it's amazing if
this were donald trump this would be the
entire news cycle endlessly because you
remember that there was an entire news
cycle during the last election cycle
over whether donald trump had visited a
world war one cemetery in europe and at
the time had made disparaging remarks
about america's fallen soldiers remember
there's an entire politico news cycle
and the atlantic had covered it it was
jeffrey goldberg over the atlantic
covering it and it was all unnamed
sources imagine if donald trump had gone
to dover air force base to
do the dignified transfer
of bodies of the american service people
who had been killed
in afghanistan and imagine if he looked
at his watch
really this is kind of an amazing story
so this is not speculative here's the
video you can decide for yourself what
joe biden is doing here he doesn't look
like he's hitting his sleeve to me he
looks like he's deliberately looking
down at his watch and then realizing he
shouldn't be looking at his watch while
waiting for the bodies of american
service members who are dead because of
his afghanistan policy
that's an amazing and and the media have
thus far really not covered it
imagine if it were donald trump right
the callousness is the point the cruelty
is the point but joe biden
was structured in afghanistan policy so
absolutely incoherent that certainly
tens of thousands of people are going to
be slaughtered by the taliban certainly
americans are going to get left behind
and now he's at a place specifically
first of all
there's a general rule that if you go to
dover air force base to do the dignified
transfer of troops to be present for
that you don't let the cameras in
right that george w bush famously did
that george w bush famously
went in the middle of the night to dover
air force base dana purina talks about
this she's his press secretary she talks
about the fact that george w bush would
go to dover air force base quietly and
without the cameras there to do the
dignified transfer
biden shows up camera's in tow and even
then he can't keep it together long
enough not to apparently look at his
watch i don't know what else to take
from that like i haven't even heard an
excuse from the white house on what he
was doing there because in the video
it's pretty damn i mean i've looked at
my watch
from time to time when i'm bored with
something and it looks exactly like that
so that's an amazing thing and again if
it were if it were donald trump all you
would hear about is how little donald
trump obviously cares about the troops
and how much of a photo op all of this
is and all the rest joe biden does it
and we're supposed to believe that he's
captain empathy over here meanwhile new
news emerging on exactly how kabul fell
to the taliban there's an entire report
in the washington post about the fall of
kabul and it talks about the fleeing of
the president of afghanistan how he was
really supposed to stay for some sort of
transition into a transitional
government that would include the
taliban which was going to be a fig leaf
but there's one part of the story that's
truly astonishing and that is joe biden
and his administration were offered
control of kabul by the taliban to
evacuate americans and joe biden turned
it down
it's in a piece titled surprise panic
and fateful choices the day america lost
its longest war by susannah george missy
ryan tyler pager pamela constable john
hudson and griff witt so like the entire
staff of the washington post
about halfway down in the article is
buried this little tidbit
u.s officials were surprised as anyone
the americans had expected ghani who was
the president of afghanistan who fled
because he was afraid he'd be
disembelled by the taliban they expected
ghani would stay for an orderly
transition to an interim authority as
the agreement that negotiators in doha
qatar had struck promised news of
ghani's departure received second hand
meant that hope had been crushed
he not only abandoned his country but
then unraveled the security situation in
kabul said a senior u.s official people
simply melted away from the airport to
everywhere else
in the void law and order began to break
down with reports of armed gangs moving
through the street
in a hastily arranged in-person meeting
senior us military leaders in doha
including brett mckenzie the commander
of ussncom
spoke to abdul ghani baradar the head of
the taliban's political wing
we have a problem baradar said according
to the us official we have two options
to deal with it you the united states
military take responsibility for
securing kabul or you have to allow us
to do it
okay so
remember this is the taliban calling up
the us and saying listen kabul is
breaking down it's in disorder we know
you're leaving anyway so here are your
options you can make sure that order is
kept in kabul with the military presence
you have left and you can evacuate your
people
or
you can trust us to do it and joe biden
chose to trust the taliban throughout
the day says the washington post biden
had remained resolute in his decision to
withdraw all american troops from
afghanistan
the collapse of the afghan government
hadn't changed his mind mackenzie aware
of these orders told baradar the us
mission was only to evacuate american
citizens afghan allies and others at
risk the united states he told baradar
needed the airport to do that on the
spot an understanding was reached
according to two other u.s officials the
united states could have the airport
until august 31st but the taliban would
control the city
fighters were now on the move throughout
kabul with the group's spokesman issuing
a revision of his earlier guidance the
taliban hadn't intended to even take
kabul that day but ghani's exit gave the
group no
choice i mean that's unbelievable so the
taliban are calling up the united states
and saying would you like to keep kabul
for the moment well you know while you
evacuate your people and keep some order
we're like nope you do it
that was the joe biden approach
meanwhile joe biden has been lying this
entire time about the unanimity of his
military advisors you noticed last week
in the aftermath of the horrific bombing
that claimed the lives of 13 american
service members and probably 165 other
people
remember in the aftermath of that
bombing joe biden got on national
television and claimed that there was
unanimity among his military advisers
about the strategy that was just an
overt lie according to the new york
times
in framing the decision before him as
either complete withdrawal or endless
escalation mr biden has been telling the
public that there was in fact no choice
at all because he knew that americans
had long since grown disenchanted with
the afghanistan war and favored getting
out
the fact that mr trump was the one to
leave behind a withdrawal agreement has
enabled mr biden to try to share
responsibility
critics consider that either
disingenuous or at the very least
unimaginative arguing there were viable
alternatives even if not especially
satisfying ones that may not have ever
led to outright victory but could have
avoided the disaster now unfolding in
kabul and the provinces megan
o'sullivan's deputy national security
advisor under george w bush that quote
the administration is presenting the
choices in a way that is at best
incomplete no one i knew was advocating
the return of tens of thousands of
americans into open combat with the
taliban indeed some of the current
military leadership of defense secretary
lloyd j austin iii and general mark
emily the chairman of the joint chiefs
asserted keeping a relatively modest
force of as few as 3 000 to 4 500 troops
along with the extensive use of drones
and close air support could have enabled
afghan security forces to continue
holding off the taliban without putting
americans at much risk
general david petraeus the retired
commander of american forces in
afghanistan and former cia director
under both biden and obama said quote
there was an alternative that could have
prevented further erosion and likelihood
and likely enabled us to roll back some
of the taliban gains in recent years he
said with the afghans doing the fighting
on the front lines and the us providing
assistance from the air such a forced
posture would have been quite
sustainable in terms of the expenditure
of blood and treasure
but the white house rejected such a
middle ground contending it amounted to
more war
so they're just lying lying lying and
the result of course is americans are
now going to be trapped in kabul trapped
in afghanistan many of them will be
slain because the question is who
reaches them first the talibans hold
them hostage for for cash or isis to
simply kill them by the way what the
taliban got in this deal
basically the result of this war is that
the taliban are now in a stronger
position than they ever were from 1996
to 2001 because the amount of armaments
that we provided them is just insane
okay this
is a graphic in the new york times on
what the taliban just received from the
united states
22 000 humvees
m1 117s
m113 armored personnel carriers 42 000
pickup trucks and suvs 64 000 machine
guns 8 000 trucks 162 000 radios 16 000
night vision goggles and devices which
by the way was the chief american
advantage in terms of special forces
because none of these people could see
in the dark but our guys could
we handed them 340 360 000 assault
rifles so just you know joe biden is
more interested in you getting an
assault rifle if you're a member of the
taliban than if you're an american
citizen if you want to buy an ar-15 in
the united states he thinks that you're
very bad and very dangerous if you're a
member of the taliban he along with his
administration will hand them 360 000
assault rifles 126 000 pistols 176
artillery pieces we handed them
33 helicopters
mi1 mi-17 helicopters we handed them 33
uh-60 blackhawks
we handed them another 43 md 530s those
are all helicopters so if you total that
up we handed them over a hundred
helicopters
we handed them fixed wing aircraft this
is what we gave to the taliban four
c-130 transports have someone pointed
out don't we have any ability to like
turn off the ignition switches here we
handed them 28 cessnas we handed them 10
cessna strike aircraft
it's unbelievable we left them an
enormous
85 billion arsenal
that is what we handed to the taliban
because joe biden is an incompetent
buffoon
it's it's unreal and by the way we also
handed them americans which we'll get to
in just one second
forget about leave no man behind now
it's how many people should we leave
behind just to placate the taliban and
pretend that there's no problem here
we'll get some more of this in a second
first let's talk about the underwear
that grace your turrets i will tell you
the only underwear i wear are tommy john
they are just that good they are
comfortable they are breathable they are
durable they are excellent apollo men's
underwear is proven to keep you drier
and up to seven degrees cooler than
regular cotton underwear that's why
tommy john doesn't have customers they
have fanatics
apollo underwear is soft supportive
stretches for the perfect fit every day
and is available up to size 4xl with
over 15 million pairs sold men across
america love tommy john underwear
because there's no more sticking or
chafing
i love wearing my tommy john underwear
as i have mentioned again i threw out
all my other underwear because tommy
john are just that good like all tommy
john underwear apollo comes with the
best pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee tommy john's new apollo men's
underwear is high end for your rear end
you can't get them anywhere else once
you go tommy john you're not going to
want any other underwear in your drawer
right now get 20 off your first order at
tommyjohn.com
again that's tommyjohn.com
for 20 off tommyjohn.com
and you can see site for details when
you use that special code slash ben
tommyjohn.com get 20 off your very first
order alrighty so
it has now become absolutely crystal
clear that we're leaving people behind
abc news is jonathan carl says yeah not
everybody is getting out
our new poll with ipsos shows just 38 of
americans approve of biden's handling of
afghanistan 84 say u.s troops should
stay in afghanistan until all americans
are evacuated that's not going to happen
and here's the interesting thing about
that poll question the second one you
mentioned 84 it's consistent it's one of
the only things i have seen for years a
question where democrats republicans and
independents all over 80 percent say
exactly the same thing that we should
stay until all americans are
re-evacuated as you point out not going
to happen
yeah so um they're not getting out jen
saki is openly admitting this she says
the u.s is not guaranteeing that
american friends and visa holders are
getting out after august 31st once we're
out
basically you're on your own
if you're a green card holder or someone
else who wants to get out
will you is the u.s guarantee that you
will be able to get out
i don't think we can guarantee but what
we can do is work toward and this is
what the president directed the
secretary of state to continue
diplomatic efforts with international
partners to secure means for third
country nationals afghans with visas who
may be eligible for our programs of
course any american citizen who remains
in country to leave the country even
after the u.s military presence ends
oh so we're going to work to get them
out we'll get to that in one second by
the way we don't even know how many
people are on the ground jake sullivan
the nsa he says we don't have a process
count on even who we're leaving it could
be 300 american citizens we really have
no clue
we have evacuated at this point nearly 5
500 american citizen citizens from kabul
we can never get an absolutely precise
count of how many americans were in
kabul because americans aren't required
to put themselves in a database as
living in afghanistan we believe that
we're down to a population of 300 or
fewer american citizens who have yet to
get out we have evacuated more than 5
000 we evacuated well more than 300 just
yesterday
so um they have no clue but they think
it's 300 but they really don't have
any idea as to how many people are stuck
on the ground by the way you've noticed
how they shrunk this down originally joe
biden said and he said over and over
we're going to get out all of the
american allies we made promises to
that went away then it was americans and
green card holders you notice the green
card holders have completely gone away
they're just not part of the
conversation anymore even though green
card holders have the same rights as
american citizens in terms of being able
to come back to the united states which
is why the united states had a real
foreign policy problem when jamal
khashoggi a non-american citizen but
green card holder was killed by the
saudi government
now they've shrunk it down to just
american citizens and then they say
we're not sure how many are out there
but we're doing a great job of getting
them out except for how you are not
there were reports last night that
american citizens were basically being
turned away from the u.s from from the
the interior ministry uh and from the
airport the administration is for the
moment denying that although we're
hearing conflicting reports
meanwhile jake sullivan that same nsa
incompetent buffoon from the obama
administration yeah he has denied that
the united states gave the taliban a
kill list right this was reported by
politico and actually followed up on by
the new york times the suggestion was
that in order to get american citizens
and siv holders special immigrant visa
holders and green card holders out the
united states had handed the taliban
lists of people to let through but that
also gave the taliban a list of people
to kill if they decided not to let those
people through
and then joe biden said last week you'll
remember who's asked specifically about
he said might have happened i don't know
he it might so now jake sullivan denies
that ever happened but admits in the
process that yeah we did give them lists
a lot of these afghan sivs as you know
better than i they think the taliban is
going to kill them and you've given them
a list of their of their names
jake we've actually aggressively and
decisively disputed that report we have
given no
list
of all of the american
siv holders to the taliban or any other
kind of big list well there was a
pentagon official in that report that
referred to this as a kill list the idea
of what you just quoted from a pentagon
official is not flat out not correct
there is no such quote-unquote kill list
that is it is nonsense it is
irresponsible and unfounded reporting
okay but then he admitted in the same
exact interview that we had in fact
given them a list
in terms of letting buses through for
example so of course we've transferred
information over to them and we have
reports that the taliban are already
going around just with captured
information that they've garnered from
american sources and they're killing
people
that of course is not a shock
meanwhile the people who are actually
doing a lot of the hard work and getting
people out are private organizations
it's like glenn beck flying
jets flying planes into afghanistan to
try and get people out
it's american special forces operators
going without american governmental
permission to go and try and get people
out
according to abc news an all-volunteer
group of american veterans of the afghan
war launched a final daring mission on
wednesday night dubbed the pineapple
express to shepherd hundreds of at-risk
afghan elite forces and their families
to safety members of the group told abc
news moving after nightfall in near
pitch black darkness and extremely
dangerous conditions the group said it
worked unofficially in tandem with the
us military and u.s embassy to move
people sometimes one person at a time or
in pairs but rarely more than a small
bunch inside the wire of the us
military-controlled side of hamid karzai
international airport so we weren't
sending american troops to do this
ourselves we were waiting for the
american troops to volunteer to do it
and then we were unofficially working
with them presumably so if they were
killed in the process biden could deny
responsibility
the pineapple express mission was
underway thursday when the attack
occurred in kabul a suicide bomber
believed to have been an isis fighter
killed at least 13 u.s service members
10 u.s marines a navy corpsman an army
soldier another service member and
wounded 15 other service members they
were wounded among the pineapple express
travelers from the blast members of the
group said they were assessing whether
unaccounted for afghans they were
helping had been killed as of thursday
morning the group said it had brought as
many as 500 afghan special operators
assets and enablers and their families
into the airport in kabul overnight
handing them each over to protective
custody of the us military that number
added to more than 130 over others over
the past 10 days who'd been smuggled
into the airport encircled by taliban
fighters
but they had to do it
via
retired army special operators and by
the way people who are helping them
working in like hotel rooms in the
united states
where the hell is the us government in
all of this
well the answer is they've been busy
handing over all power to the taliban
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that
the economy is really coming back it is
roaring back right now according to
forbes gyms nail salons hotels mom and
pop stores and more they're all set to
go on an epic hiring spree in the coming
months in fact everybody's already on an
epic hiring spree they're more open jobs
in the united states than there are
people to fill those jobs all those
businesses reopening it means that
millions of jobs will need to be filled
so where do businesses turn to fill
those roles fast they turn to zip
recruiter right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
zip recruiter.com
wire when you post a job on ziprecruiter
they send your job to over 100 top job
sites giving you access to their network
of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and proactively presents
them to you you can easily review
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply even faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zip recruiters matching
technology is so effective four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
will get a quality candidate within the
very first day right now try zip recruit
for free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
that's ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire ziprecruiter.com
dailywires zippercareer is indeed the
smartest way to hire alrighty so after
august 31st what exactly happens we're
gonna have people who are left on the
ground hundreds of thousands of people
who are made promises by the united
states left on the ground presumably to
die
the biden administration has a plan
their plan involves trusting the taliban
so for the for the last couple of months
we keep hearing from joe biden i don't
trust the taliban i don't trust the
taliban weird then that you trust the
taliban so secretary of state anthony
blinken
made the rounds yesterday and he
explained that after august 31st there
will be no american presence on the
ground in kabul so for all the talk
about how we are going to exert our best
efforts to get people out we will not
have a single human being on the ground
in kabul to make that happen so
basically that means that we're going to
be bribing people that's literally the
only way that you get this to happen
in terms of having an on the ground uh
diplomatic presence uh on september 1st
that's not likely to happen but what is
going to happen
is that our commitment uh to continue to
help
people leave afghanistan who want to
leave and who are not out by september
1st that endures there's no deadline on
that on that effort and we have ways we
have
mechanisms
to help facilitate the ongoing departure
of people from afghanistan if they
choose to leave
oh they have so many mechanisms
like real mechanisms uh you only have
one mechanism that is bribing the terror
group the taliban
and lincoln basically admitted this he
said we'll be looking to the taliban to
be our friends and help out now
um i noticed that the taliban is uh in
fact a giant terror network i noticed
that you may have noticed it as well
here's anthony blinken talking about how
the taliban are our friends now i told
you as soon as you cut a deal with
terrorists you become a pr firm for the
terrorists that's what the biden
administration is now
you may have seen that just yesterday a
very senior taliban official went on
television and radio across the country
and repeatedly assured people in
afghanistan that they would have the
freedom to travel after august 31st he
even specifically said uh those who
worked for the americans uh and uh those
who want to leave for whatever reason
will have that freedom now of course we
don't take the taliban at their word we
take them by their deed and that's what
we're going to be looking to we have
more than 100 countries 114 countries
who signed onto a statement we initiated
making clear the international community
expects the taliban to make good on a
commitment to let people continue to
leave the country after august 31st
the international community signed a
letter to the taliban guys that's how we
know people are going to get out because
if there's one thing the taliban is
deeply afraid of it's the international
community
by the way during the taliban's first
run three count them three countries
even recognize the taliban as a ruling
regime saudi arabia uae pakistan that's
it
okay so clearly the kind of pressure
that tony blinken wants to bring to bear
here you know the international
community writing nasty worded letters
to the taliban leadership the illiterate
taliban leadership that's going to work
out just fantastically well that's the
kind of pressure he means to bring to
bear
nsa jake sullivan again deep incompetent
he says the same thing he says august
31st isn't the real deadline we still
have we still have mechanisms work with
the taliban afterward
august 31st is not
a cliff after august 31st we believe
that we have substantial leverage to
hold the taliban to its commitments to
allow safe passage for american citizens
legal permanent residents and the afghan
allies who have travel documentation to
come to the united states we will use
that leverage to the maximum maximum
extent and we will work with the rest of
the international community to ensure
the taliban does not falter on these
commitments
wow we're going to work with the
international community you know it'd be
great what if the international
community had like an international
fighting force we could call it nato and
let's say that we had troops on the
ground preventing the taliban from
taking over the country in the first
place with zero american casualties what
if we just
i don't know what maybe what if we just
left that i know crazy idea right no we
drew and we handed over the entire
country to these barbarians and then
we're like but if we send them a mean
message if we dm them about how we're
going to be supes pissed if they don't
let people out then probably they'll be
really really nice by the way here is
the text of the the overwhelmingly
brutal text sent by 114 nations
including
yemen and zambia wow i mean if i'm the
taliban i'm running scared from djibouti
that said a signatory to this amazing
they sent they sent a message guys they
sent sure the taliban just ran the most
powerful military on planet earth out of
the country for no apparent reason
and sure the the mujahideen did the same
to the ussr and sure the fighters in
afghanistan now believe they can defeat
anybody who attempts to do anything to
them
and the evidence of that is that they
are now in control of american weaponry
and sure they now have the backing of
china and all of us but none of that
matters by the way one of the things
that you'll notice i'm looking at the
i'm looking at the letter right now you
know what country is not a signatory to
this
china china is not on this list
right isn't that amazing
so you would think that after all i mean
everybody is on the same page here right
you would think that probably
china would be on the list you know who
else is not on the list of countries
russia
okay so china and russia are not on the
list
of the government calling for these
people to be able to evacuate
yeah it's pretty incredible is it not
here is the text of the list quote
we are all committed to ensuring that
our citizens nationals and residents
employees afghans who have worked with
us and those who are at risk can
continue to travel freely to
destinations outside afghanistan we have
received assurances from the taliban
that all foreign nationals and any
afghan citizen with travel authorization
from our countries will be allowed to
proceed in a safe and orderly manner to
point to a departure and travel outside
the country we will continue issuing
travel documentation to designated
afghans and we have the clear
expectation of and commitment from the
taliban that can travel to our
respective countries we note the public
statements of the taliban confirming
this understanding wow overwhelming
brutal message there they told us that
they were gonna do this and therefore we
note their public statements oh you're
gonna blow their hair back there
that's some real heavy stuff right there
from the international community that
just cut and ran in the face of 8th
century goat hurting barbarians
really tough stuff
even martha raddatz who is a pretty
reliable voice in favor of democrats
even she was saying to tony blanken
you're saying we should trust the
taliban are you really
just about 24 hours ago a very senior
taliban uh leader
spoke on television and on the radio
throughout afghanistan and repeatedly
assured the afghan people that they
would be free to travel after uh august
31st
uh and he but secretary blinken they do
not trust that i mean i know you say you
don't trust the taliban but now you're
telling me we should trust what the
taliban said those people are fighting
i'm not saying that martha i'm not
saying we should trust the taliban on on
anything i'm simply reporting
what one of their senior leaders said
to the afghan people
oh yeah i'm not trusting that i'm just
i'm just reporting what they said okay
well would you report you know what
hamas says about their commitments to
the international community no you've
become their propaganda mouthpiece
that's what this administration has
become
in the same way the obama administration
became a propaganda mouthpiece for the
iranians that's exactly what you have
right now
it's unreal and by the way
at the same exact time that the taliban
is pledging that they're going to allow
people to travel
they're shooting people
okay carlotta gaul for the new york
times is reporting when taliban troops
seized control of the afghan capital two
weeks ago the invading units made a
b-line for two critical targets the
headquarters of the national security
directorate and the ministry of
communications their aim recounted by
two afghan officials who had been
briefed separately on the raid was to
secure the files of afghan intel
officers and their informers and to
obtain the means of tracking the
telephone numbers of afghan citizens
the speed with which kabul fell on
august 15th was potentially disastrous
for hundreds of thousands of afghans
who've been working to counter the
taliban threat from prominent officials
to mid-level government workers who have
since been forced into hiding few
officials found the time to shred
documents and thousands of top secret
files and payrollers fell into the hands
of the enemy two officials said
so far the taliban has presented a
moderate phase but in allying provinces
it's pretty obvious what exactly is
happening
the scale of the campaign is unclear
because it's being conducted covertly
but the fear among afghans is palpable
many people have gone into hiding
changed their locations in telephone
numbers broken off communications with
friends and colleagues people are
texting americans saying this may be the
last time i text you because they're
afraid the taliban are going to murder
them
but don't worry they're very trustworthy
in fact they are so trustworthy that
john kirby the spokesperson for the
pentagon
refused to rule out taliban's
involvement in the isis attack that
claimed 13 american lives the other day
i understand that you're reliant on them
for protection around the airport but
are you
ruling out them being involved because
you're so dependent on the taliban right
now actually i i didn't hear general
mckenzie put it that way jenna in fact i
think the uh
in one of the questions he got and i
think it was addresses you know he said
idris asked was there a failure and the
general said of course there was a
failure somewhere obviously um and he
even alluded to the fact that it could
have been um at a taliban checkpoint um
so i don't we've we've not been certain
about that at all
um
so they're openly admitting the taliban
could have just let through the isis
murderers the suicide bombers that
killed 170 people
but don't worry we trust them i mean
they did make some public statements
says tony blinken by the way kirby was
also asked about question
he was also asked about the taliban
releasing isis fighters because that is
what happened when they swept into the
prisons they just opened all the gates
and that kirby just walked away from the
question
okay i think we're going to call it a
day now we're going to call it a day
lucas lucas lucas i appreciate it very
much
thank you very much prisoners we're
releasing thank you all
today
is that evidence that the taliban isis
might be in
bye we're done catch you later
because we have to trust the taliban now
because that's the actual strategies to
trust the taliban the state department
spokesperson ned price won't even answer
if the taliban should be given a seat at
the u.n
because we have now been forced into
this position they're holding americans
hostage and american green card holders
and american allies and so they've got
the whip hand here everybody knows it
we are the most powerful country in the
history of the world with the most
powerful military in the history of the
world and we are being held hostage
by a bunch of bedraggled illiterates
who are refugees from the 7th century
now handling our drones it's unreal
here's the state department refusing to
say whether the united states would have
to back taliban's admission into the u.n
should the taliban get the afghanistan
seats in at yuan
these are not questions that we're
prepared to answer today and we are not
prepared to answer them today precisely
because
we have heard a range of statements from
the taliban
some of them
have been
positive some of them uh have been
constructive but ultimately what we will
be looking for what our international
partners will be looking for uh are
deets not words
so um we'll be looking for deeds not
words and also we're not going to rule
out just admitting them to the family of
nations
all this led yesterday to a dramatic
video of the mother of a fallen marine
riley mccollum uh that's the name of the
marine who who died in the last kabul
suicide bombing blasting joe biden now
as a general rule i do not think that it
is worthwhile to
focus in
on the family members of people who have
been tragically slain
i remember in the aftermath of 9 11
there was this real attempt by the media
to push the the 9 11 widows uh and to
and to
use them as sort of a front for their
political agenda remember maureen dowd
suggested that they had unchallengeable
moral authority uh so-called jersey
girls even though what they were saying
was not politically super coherent
but what's good for the goose is good
for the gander here and if the
democratic party continues to play this
game where every time there's a bad
thing that happens family members of the
of the slain have unending moral
authority then certainly i i think that
we should hear from the mother of fallen
marine riley mccollum here is the mother
blasting the president of the united
states
i wanted my son to represent our country
to fight for my country but i never
thought that a second piece of crap
would send him to his death and smirk on
television
while he's talking about people dying
with his nasty smirk it is so disgusting
that these people cannot even
even acknowledge the fact that they just
killed my son for nothing for an
ill-managed um
debacle of a freaking withdrawal from a
country that we had total control of
that's what gets me
yeah marine corps lieutenant colonel
stuart sheller also has been making
headlines because he is in fact as we
say a lieutenant colonel he was relieved
of his command because he put out a
video criticizing senior u.s officials
for their failures in afghanistan by the
way nobody's been held responsible for
any of this has anybody been fired of
course nobody can be fired because this
is joe biden's top down policy there's
no way to fire anybody you'd have to
fire the president of the united states
so this marine corps lieutenant colonel
named stuart sheller he put out a
two-minute video calling for some sort
of answerability from the people at the
top of the military chain who presided
over this debacle instead he was
relieved of command here is lieutenant
colonel sheller
people are upset because their senior
leaders let them down and none of them
are raising their hands and accepting
accountability or saying we messed this
up did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
did anyone do that
and when you didn't think to do that did
anyone raise their hand and say we
completely messed this up
about 18 hours after this lieutenant
colonel uploaded the video he posted
that he had been relieved of duty
he said to all my friends across the
social networks i've been relieved for
cause based on a lack of trust and
confidence as of 2 30 today my channel
command is doing exactly what i would do
if i were in their shoes i appreciate
the opportunities the command provided
to all the news agencies asking for
interviews i will not be making any
statements other than what's on my
social platforms until i exit the marine
corps
so that of course is uh no shock because
america has many issues but it's my home
it's where my three sons will become men
america is still the light shining in a
fog of chaos when my marine corps career
comes to an end i look forward to a new
beginning my life's purpose is to make
america the most lethal and effective
foreign diplomacy instrument while my
days of hand-to-hand violence may be
ending i see a new light on the horizon
semper
okay meanwhile joe biden has been
responding we'll get to the joe biden
response in uh in just one second
it is um pretty astonishing in its
incompetence as always first let us talk
about safety and security in your home
when i'm on the road i really rely on my
ring security system right because i can
check in on my house i can make sure
that i know what's going on all around
my property i can keep an eye even on my
kids with my ring alarm security system
i'm much more at ease when i'm on the
road or away from home my ring alarm
equals peace of mind you can protect
your home with ring alarm ring alarm is
a powerful affordable home security
system you can easily install yourself
it works seamlessly with other ring
products in one simple app for a special
offer go to ring.com ben it is the
perfect way to start your ring
experience keep an eye on every corner
of your house with indoor and outdoor
cams see what's happening directly from
your phone protect your home anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm go to
ring.com for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today you can build a
system that's right for your home have
it up and running in just minutes that's
ring.com
benignring.com slash ben i rely heavily
on my ring security system to make sure
i can keep an eye on my three wild kids
and you can do exactly the same make
sure you know what's going on on your
property at all times at ring.com ben
get a special offer today ring.com
for a special offer on that ring alarm
security kit alrighty getting a daily
dose of the facts has never been easier
our newest podcast is morning wire it's
dedicated to bringing you all the news
you need to know without any spin or
hidden agenda it is the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to make sure fact-based news still has a
platform we need your help to keep it
trending toward number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts leave a five-star review if
you like what you hear
also if you haven't checked out the
daily wire reader's pass yet you really
really should it is fantastic you'll get
the news no other media outlet covers
and if you sign up right now you get a
free four week trial and you can unlock
exclusive access to editorial content
that just doesn't exist anywhere else
after the trial is up our price is just
four bucks a month so sign up for your
reader's pass at dailywire.com subscribe
right now
hurry because our four week free trial
deal ends tomorrow august 31st you'll
find trending political and cultural
topics penned by everybody from me to
candace owens take for example my latest
piece it's a 4 000 word scorcher here's
what went wrong in afghanistan and what
we should have done differently or check
out our reader's past collections
different series of articles on a given
subject current collections include the
hunter biden files in blm the
organization behind a movement when you
sign up with readers pass you also get
access to the morning wire newsletter a
monday through saturday email covering
the top stories you need to know
available only to daily wire members all
of that can be yours for just four bucks
a month and act fast you can get your
free four week trial at dailywire.com
subscribe it's a great way to experience
the magic of daily wire our offer does
end tomorrow august 31st so what exactly
are you waiting for get informed get
your readers passed today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so in the aftermath of the
devastating suicide bombing last week by
isis that killed 13 americans the united
states launched a couple of
counter-strikes the idea was to pro was
to show americans that america wasn't
just receding on the world stage that we
still had the power to do what we wanted
to do so on friday usncom announced that
we had conducted an airstrike against an
isis-k planner spokesman captain bill
urban said u.s military force is
conducted and over the horizon
counterterrorism operation today notice
the language here
right it's an over the reason they keep
saying over the horizon is because joe
biden has said that we are going to be
able to conduct counter-terrorism from
quote unquote over the horizon despite
the fact that our nearest air bases are
going to be in qatar which is hundreds
of miles away and the reality is that if
you actually want to do serious damage
to your enemy you have to have eyes and
ears on the ground you have to have
somebody painting the target with a
laser you have to make sure you know
you're hitting the right people okay so
we hit somebody we don't know who they
haven't released any of the names we had
somebody who's associated with isis with
a drone and joe biden basically declared
victory the unmanned airstrike occurred
in the nangarhar province of afghanistan
indications are we killed at the target
we know of no civilian casualties said
urban that announcement came a day after
joe biden vowed to retaliate for a
terrorist attack
so it is not clear who exactly they
killed it is not clear exactly how high
up they were in the isis food chain so
until we find out that i think a little
skepticism is warranted given the fact
that the biden administration has
literally lied about everything else
throughout this entire process so if we
killed some isis higher ups then kudos
if we killed some
low-level lackey for isis and this is
supposed to somehow alleviate the
problem of us having withdrawn from an
entire country of 38 million people and
handing it over to the taliban al qaeda
and isis i have doubts it's very much
akin to the bill clinton strategy of
osama bin laden bombs a couple of
american embassies so we shoot a camel
in the ass in somalia
it seems a lot more like that meanwhile
there's a second attack in kabul by the
united states it was supposedly directed
against a series of suicide bombers who
had gotten into a car that was the
initial report now it's turning out that
may not be the entire story according to
cnn nine members of one family including
six children were killed in u.s drone
strike targeting a vehicle in a
residential neighborhood of kabul a
relative of the dead told a local
journalist working with cnn now you can
you always have to wait to see what
facts come out here because you see
these sorts of reports in terror-prone
regions nearly everywhere that every
time the united states hits the target
whether it was in iraq or in afghanistan
it was very easy to see somebody come
out of the woodwork and claim that had
been a big strike against civilians you
see the same thing every time israel
strikes a hamas target in the gaza strip
for example you'll have messengers of
hamas who tried out front to say how
many children were killed and that it
was really an attack on civilians et
cetera et cetera so we'll have to wait
to see what is reliable what is not this
is at least what cnn is reporting the
u.s carried out a defensive airstrike in
kabul targeting a senior targeting a
suspected isis k suicide bomber who
posed an imminent threat to the airport
according to centcom the youngest killed
was a two-year-old girl according to a
brother of one of those killed he said
they were an ordinary family we are not
isis or daesh this was a family home
where my brothers lived with their
families
neighborhood neighbors and witnesses at
the scene of the drone striking cobble
told cnn several people were killed
including children a neighbor told cnn
quote all the neighbors tried to help
and brought water to put out the fire i
saw there were five or six people dead
the father of the family and another
young boy and there were two children
they were dead they were in pieces that
were also too wounded another neighbor
told cnn they estimated there might have
been 20 people killed in the strike not
much is left of their house nothing can
be recognized they are in pieces
the us military acknowledged later
sunday there were reports of civilian
casualties following the strike
in an incredibly weak statement captain
bill urban he said quote we know there
are substantial and powerful subsequent
explosions resulting from the
destruction of the vehicle indicating a
large amount of explosive material
inside that may have caused additional
casualties it's unclear what may have
happened we are investigating further
the uh the people on the ground there
have been releasing lists of of the
folks that they claimed been killed
including an afghan interpreter who was
working with the americans allegedly
again i say allegedly on all this
because all the information is still
emerging so i keep emphasizing that it's
uncertain because in fact it is
uncertain at this point
the vehicle that was targeted by the us
in sunday's airstrike was next to a
building it contained at least one
suicide bomber according to u.s official
it remains unclear if the vehicle was
intended to be a car bomb or if the
suicide bomber was using it for
transport the official says it was
loaded up and ready to go
apparently the threat could also have
been a car bomb or somebody with a
suicide vest and urban said that they
were assessing the possibilities of
civilian casualties that we have no
indications at this time
also the united states remains on high
alert in the waning hours of the
american movement outside of afghanistan
uh they're alert to to the possibility
of future terrorist attacks meanwhile
joe biden is focused in on all that
which matters apparently according to
the telegraph in the uk joe biden's
advisers have been telling people that
he will quote unquote hold grudges and
will punish britain for afghanistan
because people in britain have been
criticizing him and saying that he is
senile
so i have my doubts number one that he
will remember nearly anything i i don't
think that joe biden is in a state to
remember nearly anything
at this point
but the fact that he is expending effort
at this point being angry at people when
it is so clear that he has not only
blown this but that he's leaving people
behind is truly astonishing don't worry
within the week we'll be hearing after
the united states withdraws leaving
hundreds of if not thousands of people
behind
you'll be hearing in the coming week i'm
sure the words of general hank taylor
deputy director of the joint staff for
regional operations talking about what a
wonderful triumph this was for the
united states even as the taliban take
full control of kabul here was the
general hank taylor
today i can report an updated total
evacuation that is more than
one hundred and seventeen thousand the
vast majority of which are afghans of
this total number approximately five
thousand four hundred are american
citizens
okay so again massive massive win
according to the people who um who
bombed the uh the
below decks of the titanic look how many
people we've unloaded and uh yeah forget
about the people we're leaving behind
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
joe biden refuses to answer questions
about afghanistan a prominent democrat
claims that ron desantis is much worse
than donald trump and a top performing
pop star plays the race card check it
out on the michael knowles show